[Music]
now for years on this program we've
exposed the politicization of the
justice department and the weaponization
of intelligence and criminalizing
political differences and of course the
biggest abuse of power corruption
scandal in u.s history that of course
being the russia hoax and one of the
main figures targeted in mueller's witch
hunt and the deep state's efforts to
destroy donald trump and his allies and
his family his former trump campaign
manager paul manafort mueller and his
team wanted paul manafort to die in jail
and they tried hard and they also put
him in solitary confinement for nearly a
year why to hope to break him ask
yourself prosecutors destroyed his life
where's the accountability for those
that filed false information with the
fisa court those that use the dirty
disinformation
russian hillary clinton
bought and paid for russia
misinformation dossier
listened to christopher steele even when
they knew it was false they continued to
use the dossier illegally spying on
candidate trump transition team trump
president trump now last year paul
manafort was pardoned by president trump
he's now ready to tell his side of the
story he has a forthcoming book it's
called political prisoner it will be out
uh fairly soon revealing new details
about the unequal standard of justice
and the russia hoax he joins us now for
his first interview since being pardoned
uh paul manafort well you look you look
healthy i'm sure it's better wearing a
suit and tie than an orange suit right
it's great to be here with you sean
after all these years yes thank you very
much i appreciate this opportunity today
you really in many ways you roger stone
papadopoulos
general flynn and you know
carter page the president himself
um all of this stems from a false phony
narrative based on a false dossier and
phony fisa warrants tell us about the
whole experience from your point of view
well i mean from my point of view it's
been a very
complicated level the last five years
and certainly not a fun experience
a lot of surprises when things first
started to break and the false narrative
first started to be promoted in august
of 2016 i didn't take it very seriously
because i knew how ridiculous it was to
even say that there was russian
collusion going on with the trump
campaign
but as time went on and as the drum beat
got louder and all of a sudden anonymous
government sources started putting out
stories which i knew were fake
uh in in
working with social media and the
mainstream media to promote this concept
that there was serious investigation
going on with the people around donald
trump and particularly around
people like me and roger stone
i said
how do i how do i combat this i felt
like i was in the middle of a tsunami
you know and there's no way my voice was
going to be heard against all of this
onslaught of
misinformation
uh and and then of course when they did
ultimately indict me they threw a gag
order on me and made it impossible for
me to speak even though they kept
leaking stories that were have been
proven false
and then when i started to
fight against that gag order they threw
me in jail
where you know they deliberately knew
what they were doing they didn't want me
to speak to uh
uh to the media they wanted to keep me
from my lawyers and affect my ability to
prepare for my trial and and frankly you
know from day one i always felt they
were targeting me and a couple of others
to try and get at the president with the
president then candidate trump and then
president trump uh which is one of the
reasons why i find it sort of ironic
that uh what's going on today with this
these claims about january 6 when the
people who are pushing the january 6th
allegations are the very ones who for
four and a half years refused to
recognize the results of the 2016
election
so this book that i'm writing is is
meant to you know tell my side of the
story get out my side of the facts to
tell the truth about my career in
politics and government uh and to uh and
to
let the reader understand what really
was going on
in the in the trump power meeting of
june 9.
you mentioned the gag order roger stone
similarly had a gag order i thought we
had something called the first amendment
that allows you to speak out but
apparently i must i must have been to a
bad catholic school for 12 years um
but that was taken away from you then
they put you in solitary confinement and
i don't know how much you want to reveal
here before the book comes out
um
were there
specific moments
where they were offering to set you free
if you said certain things
well there were moments and i will talk
about this in the book when they were
putting pressure on me to admit the
facts that weren't true and i'll talk
about those facts and those those
expectations uh and the and the
the quid pro quo that was understood was
that i would be treated in a very
lenient way
they didn't understand that there was no
way i was going to lie
there was no way that they could force
me
into to giving up the president uh yeah
and
and i i never felt uncomfortable talking
to them because i knew that as long as i
told the truth
there i had nothing to fear but i was
wrong
because even though the truth was the
reason then
what was the reason for solitary
confinement my interpretation was they
were trying to break you uh and i
remember at the time you were suffering
some health issues as a result of it um
were the were they afraid for your
safety
how were the prisoners when you got to
finally see them uh did they treat you
well were they nice to you
or were they a threat to you
now the prisoners were never an issue
with me uh the special prosecutor was
they're the ones who uh
uh put me into into what i viewed as
harm's way so that's why solitary is a
terrible thing
why is it terrific
well they said it was to protect me um
but i mean i never believed that for a
minute i mean it did it didn't protect
me and what it did was it put me into a
situation that was you know in an eight
by ten room with no windows uh you know
in you know with no access to people no
access to outside uh and uh
and limited ability to communicate with
my lawyers um and i talk about that in
the book and talk about how you know
it's inhumane what they call solitary
confinement then they even tried to get
me to go to rikers island that uh and
forced me to be there
in solitary which fortunately thanks to
the department of justice uh that didn't
happen uh because there was a fear of
issue of safety for me in any outlet
context there
only because of the constraints of time
i'm not trying to interrupt you but i
know what we'll we'll do a full hour
when you're when your book does come out
because this there's details that you've
told me that when people hear it we'll
be blown away
i'm trying to ask this in a way that we
don't give away the whole book here
because you and you also talk about the
campaign and and how mike pence
was chosen and you bring us behind the
scenes and the work that you were do
that you were doing
my sources have been telling me for a
long time that robert mueller he was
kind of checked out let me i'm being
nice in other words he kind of suffered
from
the same cognitive decline that joe
biden has
a is that true did you see him much and
b
if it wasn't him
who is putting all this pressure on you
his hitman uh mr weissman
yeah i never was i saw robert mullet
walking down the hallway once uh other
than that i had no contact with him and
frankly he didn't look like he knew who
i was when i met when i saw him um
uh yes it was weissman i mean he was the
one that was the lead uh prosecutor on
my pitbull and from day one he was
he was the one who i mean
they so overcharged me in my case that
judge ellis in virginia actually
admonished them from the bench saying
why are you bringing all of these
charges you want to put this guy to jail
for forever
and they were trying to put me in jail
forever i mean if i they unless i would
cooperate that was what they what they
were promising to do and in fact
uh you know
when we did the presentation in the
virginia dc case they argued for the
maximum penalty for me um
because they didn't want me
to to be free even though you had you
had a total agreement well let me let me
ask this
and i want to stay on
on mueller's pitbull andrew weissman for
a second here
were there moments
that you knew
that
they wanted you to say what they wanted
you to say whether it was true or not
because they wanted their real target
was donald trump not paul manafort i'm
asking if this is true
and that if you would have said it you
probably could have walked out free
were there very specific things that
they were
looking for you to say and telling you
wink nod
you know you can go home and have pizza
tonight if you give us the answer we're
looking for
well i'll be definitely talking about
some of those details in the book
because there was no doubt in my mind
from day one that i was a means to an
end and frankly after they didn't
succeed with me they used the same
tactics against roger stone i mean they
did the morning no knock uh uh
breaking into his house just as they did
at my house they uh you know the only
difference was they had a cnn camera
there because he lived in an open
community not in a condominium
you know they put the gag order on roger
they indicted him too so i mean the
technique that they used on him and me
was not because they cared about either
of us who they cared about was donald
trump and we were the way they without
us they didn't think they could get
trump and uh you know i remember
laughing to my lawyer uh when uh
when when i
did the plea agreement with them in the
virginia in the dc case that there's all
kind of stories that donald trump was
going down now paul manafort was going
to turn on him and i turned to my lawyer
i said look make sure they understand i
plan on telling the truth because when i
tell the truth not only is donald trump
not going down
but their whole case is going to blow up
and that's what happened and that's why
afterwards let me ask you about this um
was it clear to you that they wanted you
to lie about they didn't care if you
lied about donald trump that their
target was donald trump and that it that
you basically
they wanted you to lie about him now
when you're talking about then remember
they wanted you to die in jail
just
you know they were wanting what 25 years
they wanted you dead in jail
so
now you're being basically offered your
freedom if you say what they want
what what they want to hear
but you didn't do it
why
why why didn't you you know that that's
a pretty that's a strong incentive
well they wanted me to say something
that wasn't true and i wasn't going to
do that and
you know and frankly you know once you
start walking down that slippery sleeve
who knows where you end up i wasn't
going to do that um you know i mean i
felt comfortable from day one on the
whole russian collusion narrative that
it was i knew it was phony i i and every
in the book i walked through all of the
elements of the prosecutor's case on
russian collusion and show that from
adam schiff to everyone else who said
they had inside information they had
seen confidential information i expose
all of that in the book because the
truth is there was no confidential
information they didn't have any secret
information yeah there was it was a
weaponization of the law enforcement the
national security operations and
targeted you know in my wildest dreams i
couldn't have imagined this
targeting a president of the united
states uh to undermine his presidency
and to try and remove him from office
and uh
there was no way i was going to ever be
a participant in that
that
you know what i what i've concluded paul
as a result of this we don't have in
america anymore and it saddens me to say
equal justice under the law we don't
have equal application under the law we
now have the criminalization of criminal
of political differences in this country
and prosecutorial abuse
is
far more rampant than people know
i can't wait to get the details you've
given me a couple little tidbits
off camera that i can't wait for you to
tell the country their eyes will open
wide when this book comes out and uh
thank you for sharing your time with us
tonight the book is called political
prisoner you can get it on a first
edition copy on amazon.com all right
paul manafort hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else